If a person breaks their ankle, and the bones
no longer line up with each other, a doctor
may need to perform a surgical procedure to
reposition and secure the bones.
The ankle is the joint that connects the leg
and the foot.
The ankle joint includes the two lower leg
bones called the tibia and fibula, and the
ankle bone called the tailus.
Together, the end of the tibia and fibula
create a whartos or “slot” for the talus
which forms the bottom of the ankle joint.
Tissues called ligaments and tendons support
the ankle bones.
Ligaments attach bones to bones, and tendons
attach muscles to bones.
The ankle joint allows the foot to move up
and down.
Ankle injuries usually happen during athletic
activities, falls, or car accidents.
The most common type of ankle fracture occurs
when the foot turns inward, and the ankle
rotates outward.
If the fracture is stable, the pieces of bone
still line up in their normal position.
In any type of fracture, more than one bone
may break.
In a displaced fracture, the pieces of bone
no longer line up.
If bone breaks through the skin, it’s known
as a compound or “open” fracture.
In addition to broken bones, the ankle may
be sprained.
This means the ligaments have been stretched
or torn.
If the ankle is very swollen, the surgeon
may delay a surgical procedure to allow the
swelling to go down.
During this time, the surgeon may put the
ankle in a splint to provide support.
During this time, the surgeon may recommend
elevating the ankle above the level of the
heart and applying ice to it.
To treat a stable ankle fracture, the healthcare
provider may put the leg in a cast or a boot
to keep the ankle from moving so that the
bones can heal together.
Displaced and compound fractures with multiple
broken bones and torn ligaments may require
a surgical procedure.
The most common surgical procedure to repair
a displaced open fracture is called an open
reduction with internal fixation.
To begin, the surgeon will make an incision
over the area of the fracture.
The surgeon will open up the area to feel
the pieces of bone and line them back up with
each other.
A plate and screws will be used to keep them
aligned.
Additional screws may be inserted through
another incision to hold other fracture fragments
in place.
If the ligaments holding the tibia and fibula
together are severly damaged, the surgeon
will place a screw through both bones, or
a suture device may be placed through both
bones.
Either of these devices will help hold the
bones together while the ligaments heal.
At the end of the procedure, the surgeon will
close any skin incisions with stitches.